ready to break in then use some pliers
are you the chosen one who can pull it
out I'm gonna end up removing the shaft
from the metal tip got it sorry dude
look at that hole Dookie magic any shot
with one of these things about a month
ago we had someone wash and write
fraudulent checks from our account
stealing almost four thousand dollars
from us went to Chase Bank they were
super helpful I submitted a fraud claim
it went through their system and now
finally today we've gotten our money
back so thank you for the FDIC for
insuring our money and for the
infrastructure of the United States in
keeping us secure in our persons papers
transactions and homes this is a regular
law but is transparent Spencer just
shows up with cool toys every now and
then it's really fun so he's like
alright this is a lock he can see
through something he's like so you must
know what this is oh man I have no idea
how to pick a lock this lock is stupid
easy is it ok so I haven't done anything
in like years like the last time I
researched this was in middle school so
I believe the way you do this is put
this here and it's just so you can apply
pressure and then you stick the pick in
you start pushing each tumbler lock
start from the back oh tell me all hot
Jesus are you part of that yeah
54.3 we warm cheese we've got one over
here 57 ruins tool is very useful I
might have to borrow it for the next
cheese batch if you like my forehead
like alhazen forehead
we're at well oh what a why not for your
forehead your tongue is ninety seven
this shirt will never be available
forever from this point forward so if
you want to get this shirt today is the
last day to buy it go to corridor -
digital comm slash store and this is
your last day to buy all the ladies will
fall in love with you if your guy and
all the guys will fall in love with you
here lady
and if you have other preferences your
preferences will fall in love with you
if you wear - no idea what I'm doing
supposed to be working man well if you
if you were better at this you would be
back to working alright let's see you do
it I've always wanted to get good luck
picking
this is just over a week old right here
and the mold start growing on the
outside wants to complete the coward I
will wrap it up and I let it sit in the
fridge for a couple weeks and then
that'll turn debris I actually managed
to find some raw milk I thought it's
like super illegal because you just read
posted about raw milk farms being raided
and how dumb it is and all kind of stuff
turns out you just walk into a fancy
grocery store and buy it it's there it's
not illegal it's just uh they have to
test it and make sure it's coming from
very clean sources and so maybe the
farmer wasn't doing that who got raided
the raw milk gives you the creamiest
most flavorful cheese and that is why
European cheese's tend to be better than
American cheese's because American
cheese's can't use unpasteurized milk
I've got around the rules and I figured
out how to make my own cheese have you
ever picked a real lock yeah the ladders
at the end of the hall take this tool
and you put it in here and then you just
go back and forth yeah see if you can do
that one this guy goes in that's a
pressure that and then just go back and
forth back and forth and keep pushing
pressure on that
there we go
I can't I can't seem to get it even with
the cheater tool
wait up go look at me go beautiful